hochzeiten mit hunderten von gästen
paradies im tag überfüllten kneipen
masten muffel auf dem vormarsch die lage
in deutschland spitzt sich weiter zu
über 4000 neuinfektionen die werte sind
so hoch wie zuletzt im april
jetzt werden die maßnahmen wieder
verschärft sperrstunde in großstädten
alkohol verkaufsverbote private feiern
in berlin nur noch mit maximal zehn
gästen einige bundesländer haben sogar
beherbergungs verbote für gäste aus
innerdeutschen hotspots verhängt gerade
jetzt zum beginn der herbstferien das
unverständnis in der bevölkerung wächst
ist die geduld der menschen langsam am
ende so und wenn ihr jetzt dein puls
messen würde dann würden wir bei der
schnurstracks durch die decke fliegen
habe ich so sind endlos erklären also
ich finde dass die cola maßnahmen
langsam ein level erreicht haben was
auch einfach nicht mehr in ordnung ist
weil ich finde dass immer noch viele
menschen sind ja menschen die denken
können wir sind ja keine roboter die die
sagen was positioniert werden müssen und
ich finde jetzt ein beherbergungs verbot
zu machen
man muss sich die regelung mal kurz
überlegen ich arbeite in berlin in einem
der sogenannten risikogebiete in meinem
pass weil ich nicht aber derzeit noch
nicht umgemeldet habe was sie jetzt
machen muss steht aber noch düsseldorf
sei es laut meinem reisepass könnte ich
ja jetzt reisen obwohl ich dort arbeite
wo verbringt man meistens mehr zeit wo
man arbeitet oder wo man lebt und das
ist ja selbst innerhalb von von den
städten sohn ich finde auch dieses
alkoholverbot jetzt und ich finde die
ganzen maßnahmen irgendwann muss man
doch mal anfangen darüber nachzudenken
wo geht diese reise eigentlich hin und
ich bin der festen überzeugung dass wir
irgendwann nicht darüber reden werden
dass corona die schlimmste pandemie war
sondern dass vor allem die politischen
entscheidungen zu einer riesigen
wirtschaftskrise geführt haben aber
meinst du nicht dass es einen grund gibt
für das ganze also im endeffekt ist es
ja auch so wenn wir es nicht so gemacht
hätten
ja und vielleicht alles einfach nach dem
motto gelebt hatten hängen lose dann
hätten wir es vielleicht ganz andere
zahlen
ich glaube nicht dass ihre negativen
andere zu absolut ich glaube auch nicht
dass man nach dem motto leben soll hey
es gibt kein coruna ich bin ja keine
verschwörungstheoretikern aber ich
glaube dass man den menschen mehr eigene
verantwortung überlassen sollte
glücklich bin nach den bildern von der
hochzeit
wir gesehen haben den bildern von der
hochzeit die wir gerade gesehen haben ja
dann haben die eine fehlentscheidung
getroffen so groß zu sein dass das kann
man auch gerne von mir aus verbieten
großveranstaltung da bin ich auch dafür
aber man muss doch mal überlegen was
passiert ist in deutschland durch die
korona maßnahmen wir haben ein maß an
denunziantentum in deutschland erreicht
ich meine mit den masken ja es ist ja
eigentlich die bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel hatte gesagt was getragen wenn
der abstand nicht gewährleistet ist ja
ziemlich gut sehe ich auch so
aber es ist ja jetzt so passiert ist
einfach alle gesagt okay immer maske
tragen im ic immer maske tragen im
flugzeug überall
ich war letztens in einem menschenleeren
flughafen weil es morgens um sieben war
es dann ja nicht mehr viele flugzeuge in
hamburg dann bin ich also ohne maske
durch diese menschenleere halle gegangen
und dann lief mir die polizei von oben
von irgendwo oben haben sie mich gesehen
rund angesagt bitte ziehen sie ihre
masken dann habe ich angefangen zu
diskutieren das ja kein einziger mensch
um mich herum war dann war
regeln sind regeln und mein problem
einen kroner maßnahmen derzeit ich
glaube das wird jetzt immer immer
schlimmer mit diesem des menschen zu
einem sagen regeln sind regeln und immer
unverhältnismäßiger ist dass viele
menschen anfangen den eigenen verstand
auszuschalten und das finde ich ganz
ganz china aufhalten aber wie viel
eigener verstand da jemals war und ich
finde das beweisen genau diese bilder
also dann für hochzeiten sehen wenn wir
partys den menschen die jetzt gerade auf
teufel komm raus sich das ja wort geben
wollen die geben sich auch das ja wort
dazu dass ihre ihre gäste potenziell
sterben könnten
ich finde es unfassbar egoistisch und da
steht eben oft dem freien willen auch
gegenüber
aber da muss man sich die zahlen mal
angucken also derzeit prozentual die
chance an krone zu sterben liegt bei ich
glaub 0,00 0 4
so also jetzt nicht so also es ist es
eher dass du morgen beim autounfall
stirbt also ancona stirbt das ist
einfach fakt aber wenn man sich die
zahlen vergegenwärtigt und ist ja so
dass es in den letzten sieben tagen zu
über 16.000 neue infektionen kam und die
allein die gestrige zahl von gestern von
4000 ist ja nichts was sozusagen
ausgedacht worden ist sondern dass
sozusagen finde ich ja auch setzten
gesunden menschenverstand voraus dass
wir uns da natürlich auch in der
vorsorgemaßnahme anwendung befinden und
die tatsache dass diese weltweite
pandemie von der wir ja alle
gleichermaßen betroffen sind dass sie in
deutschland sozusagen nicht so wirksamer
empfehlen wie in vielen anderen
man hat ja auch was mit den maßnahmen zu
tun und da finde ich man sehr wenige
verbote im raum
es ging um eine charakterfestigkeit die
hat jens spahn heute ja auch in der pkv
heftiger weise klar dass es ist jeder
muss zurückziehen und jeder muss sich
verbessern das ist zwar genauso wenig
wie die pandemie kennen kennt genau sie
und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen dass ich
so ein bisschen schockiert bin davon
dass sozusagen ja so zufall gemeiner ja
und ich finde es ganz ganz wichtig dass
es maßnahmen gibt denn ich kenne auch
menschen die von corona betroffen sind
ich weiß wie sie kraft dieses virus hat
und 10.000 menschen sind gestorben
das ist sozusagen im verhältnis zu
amerika geringer prozentsatz in der
wintersaison als 200.000 gestorben bei
330 millionen us-bürgern sage ich meine
wir sind ja gerade mal 83 millionen
das heißt es muss ja auch maßnahmen
gegeben haben wir werden die ganzen jahr
wahrscheinlich unter sterbliche gerade
die dazu beigetragen haben
er bringt es nichts glaube ich zu
korrelieren mit zahlen und dann zu sagen
gut ich sind aber nicht genug gestorben
oder es müssten mehr sterben damit diese
maßnahmen griffen da kommen die
sozialisation winter ist das ist für
evtl
auf der fitte nein das ist mir das
totschlag argument dafür dass ich sage
ich finde nicht alle maßnahmen gerecht
ankommen du willst dass menschen sterben
nächsten duell ist jährlich ungefähr ist
es meine oma sagt nur ich finde dann
muss man nicht widersprochen mag ich
will weg von diesem trio ich finde es
ist ganz schwierig zu jeder maßnahme
sagen wir ist schon okay was die
regierung macht und wenn dann nach dem
morden gesagt wird die maßnahme war
jetzt doch nicht notwendig ja dem des
virus ist ihr vorspann fehlers stimmt
doch gar nicht wir leben noch nicht in
nordkorea persönlichen unrechtsstaat wir
leben doch in einer demokratie also auch
immer behaupten sie hätten auferlegte
maulkörbe also das entspricht nicht der
wahrheit im gegenteil wir können ja hier
alles loswerden wir haben sogar
teilweise menschen die auf die straßen
gehen mit holocaust-leugnern mit
verfassungsfeinden und sagen es gibt
kein corona das eine erfindung wir
können ja sogar behaupten dass das
bildet diese krankheit erfunden hat und
müssen das stehenlassen
dass das stimmt doch gar nicht wir haben
derzeit finde ich zwei lager in
deutschland ja also also diese
verschwörungstheoretiker dazu gehören
übrigens definitiv nicht es gibt ja wir
haben einen programmteil anrufen wir
müssen
nein wir müssen maßnahmen treffen das
sehe ich auch so und dann gibt es die
und was mich eigentlich am meisten an
kurz derzeit in deutschland ist die
moralische überheblichkeit und diese
moralische überheblichkeit der menschen
mit ihrem hashtag wir bleiben zu hause
ich trage gerne maske sehe ich drei
wochen später die gleiche person auf
einer hochzeit wo sie sich nicht um
abstand stadt aber öffentlich sagt wie
gerne sie maske trägt und diese
moralische überheblichkeit der zeit dass
man menschen nicht mehr ernst im team
problem den maßnahmen haben aber diese
moralische überheblichkeit die du
anschließend das vielleicht nicht sogar
uns vor einer noch größeren katastrophe
gewarnt die letzten monate was meinst du
dazu also ich finde ehrlich gesagt mit
blick auf die zahlen dann spricht er mal
für die neue infektionen wie hd 4000
jahren ehrlicherweise bevor die
regierung mir noch mehr maßnahmen gibt
hätte ich gerne mal zahlen an die ich
mich auch wirklich halten kann bei im
moment das ist eigentlich möchte zwar
aus studenten die du das erklärte jetzt
mein problem meine ganzen kroner
diskussion oder auch in den maßnahmen
ist eigentlich wir sprechen ja immer nur
von infektionen
aber eigentlich müsste man mal den wert
sehen wer an krone dann auch wirklich
erkrankt ist oder auch daran gestorben
ist aber das problem ist dass die haben
ja man muss ja eigentlich dass man
statistisch auch noch krasser
aufbereiten weil natürlich wenn man
schreibt 4000 neuinfektionen denken alle
am tag
okay das ist jetzt mega krass aber es
gibt auch wirklich auch sehr sehr
leichte verläufe und wir haben auch ich
bin nicht sagen dass mona genauso ist
wie die gruppe aber wir leben auch jedes
jahr mit der grippewelle und ich finde
halt einfach wenn wir diese maßnahmen
alle treffen dann hätte ich gerne mal
aufgedröselt höhere zahlen
ich hätte auch gerne ganz viel aber der
anteil nicht bei wünsch dir was war das
ist zukunftsmusik ich meine fakt ist
dass wir uns in einer weltweiten
pandemie befinden dass wir dafür sorgen
müssen dieses infektionsrisiko ein zudem
dass die maßnahmen jetzt eine reaktion
sind aber die mauer eine erhöhte weil
infektionsrisiko und das beispielsweise
auch sozusagen die reaktion unsererseits
gegen ein schneeballsystem dafür zu
sorgen dass diese bälle die jetzt in die
luft geschossen werden sozusagen vom
markt genommen werden indem wir uns alle
ein bisschen an die eigene nase fassen
dass menschen jetzt auch aufgrund das
entscheidend jedoch nicht jeden tag also
das ist doch wirklich ich finde die
verhältnismäßigkeit der gegeben ja und
ich würde das ist eine zumutbare
zumutung ist und ich sage mach und immer
darauf an mehr dazu was land und wer
darüber redet dann sitzen viele frauen
denken wir dann aber oder gehen davon
aus
aber der andere punkt ist dass menschen
die von co
betroffen sind die vorher auch ganz
große töne gespuckt haben und ich kenne
einige davon
die sind wirklich verstummt und die sind
zum beispiel so weit dass sie sagen
mäßigen die maßnahmen nicht weit genug
also die frage ist ja wer fordert was
und dieser virus ist sehr sehr stark und
ist das ist doch diese das ist doch
dieser dieser diesel genau das ist immer
da sind immer die argumente immer und
dann sage ich klar kann ich alles
nachvollziehen arbeits beispielsweise
jetzt ein sehr spannendes interview im
handelsblatt mit dem
entwicklungsminister der gesagt hat
aufgrund des lockouts sterben jetzt mehr
menschen als die japan kroner sterben
werden da ging es halt um afrika und die
entwicklungsländer
so jetzt kann man natürlich sagen der
vor allem für eigentlich wenn wir heute
nicht an ihn dann wir sind ja nicht
wichtiger sterben jetzt nicht aufgrund
des virus ist die sterben nicht aufgrund
von hunger gut also wenn ich sagen will
ist eigentlich zu den massnahmen ich
finde dass man maßnahmen hinterfragen
musst du genau jede einzelne frank und
ich finde aber vor allem sollte man auch
menschen ernst nehmen für die es nicht
ein kennst du jemanden corona erkrankt
ist ja okay und wie und wie verlief das
dafür den menschen nur diesem jahr gut
ihr ja er sieht das genau so wie ich
auch meine meinung und er hatten einen
sehr starken verlauf hat trotzdem eine
meinung anraten eher leichteren verlauf
für beide was haben sie gesagt wie eine
grippe erkrankung bei dem ein wagen hat
ein bisschen länger
aber ich glaube wir zeigen ja immer
diese ich finde das ist heutzutage schon
fast ist es ja fast normal geworden dass
man sagt ich finde es völlig okay eine
maske zu tragen
das sehe ich aber anders es ist keine
normalität dass wir mit einer maske
rumrennen müssen und es darf auch nicht
zu normal in dieser welt namens 1 jagen
weil das ist ja immer eine diskussion
die immer wieder haben ja es ist eine
freiheitsberaubung sich lara könnt ihr
mal ganz kurz ja aber den was eine
freiheitsberaubung seien andere länder
schauen was eine freiheitsberaubung ist
die lachen sich kaputt wie ernsthaft
hier in deutschland darüber diskutieren
dass ein stückchen stoff im gesicht von
uns als freiheitsberaubung damit ihr da
ist das und ich im luxus leben und die
neue freiheit und das finde ich ein
luxusproblem winkler ja also gerade aber
filmladen in hinblick darauf also wir
uns gerade angesprochen was heißt
eigentlich unfreiheit
darin geht an die frauen die für ihre
selbstbestimmung gehen sie auf die
straße gehen gefängnis müssen ich denke
an die männer die gehängt werden weil
sie von ihrer meinungsfreiheit gebrauch
machen und du sind das eine maske
wirklich freiheit ist für mich ist eine
frau us gefreite aber vor allem das ist
für mich schluss sich doch auch ich
verstehe das ganze handy einer das habe
ich probiert zu erklären nicht soja
beispiel letztens habe ich mir sogar der
saß eine ältere frau neben ihrem viel
habe ich gesehen als ich reinkam mir
nicht nach vorne gegangen weil ich hatte
thurk können sie mir bitte den masken
geben das ist eine ältere frau neben ja
ich hab ich damals gar angezogen
ihr eigener menschenverstand ich bin
reingegangen habe entschieden da sonst
eine ältere frau ich brauche was das
dickeres unsinn zu schützen
natürlich wäre würde es nicht tun aber
wenn ich bei kam es zum beispiel
reinkommen letztens in düsseldorf
passiert vor zwei wochen mit meiner
freundin die verkäuferin steht das ist
diese schutzwand da ich stehe ihr
gegenüber das waren mindestens 150 wenn
nicht sogar drei meter und sie sagt zu
mir an kein einziger mensch im laden
bitte ziehen sie ihre maske auf dann
sage ich aber hier ist keiner im laden
und wir haben den abstand unsere
bundeskanzlerin hat gesagt was getragen
den abstand nicht gewährleistet ist
das ist eine vorgabe von kommst dann
habe ich meine meinem ein tuch genommen
ich habe jetzt keine maske 2 hab das
tuch um gemacht das würde auch nicht
gehen es wenn du erlaubt mit einer maske
dann bin ich rausgegangen habe ich zu
der frau gesagt dass auf meiner
menschenverstand und regeln sind regeln
ich finde wenn wir aufhören unseren
menschenverstand zu benutzen um auf
leute anzusprechen ich meine wenn kein
einziger im zugabteil - er sitzt warum
du kannst was menschen die diese
maßnahmen befürworten nicht in
menschenverstand absprechen das ist doch
finde ich so der ring für ihn da ist
doch kein entrinnen wenn gabmann grad
gar nicht infiziert werden kann warum
sollte die person 400 euro hätte die
müssen also wo er neben mir sitzt im
ganzen etage soll ich immer an stecken
ja gut aber die frage ist ja warum du da
sozusagen dann auch so so so intolerant
darauf reagiert weil wenn diese frau
beispielsweise diese regeln hat auch
über ihren arbeitgeber also tut das weh
also dann die ich finde einfach dass man
das der menschenverstand bei jeder
person entscheiden sollte ja aber er
kann nicht jeder so wie du ihn das kann
noch nicht wieder so wie du das ist ja
du bist selbst bestehen gibt es eine
einheitliche retten aber je mehr leute
die sind auch abhängig sind
abhängigkeitsverhältnissen dann habe
noch das verhältnis deutschland und
anderen ländern
frage ist es gerade sinnvoll warum
laufen wenn sie gar kein anstrengend ein
nein ja natürlich
obwohl ich mich tatsächlich in vielen
dinge in diesen wieder fällt aber in
einer sache möchte ich dir beispringen
ich finde schon und das müssen wir schon
sehen dass die korona regeln derzeit
absurde während ich mich über moore sich
und lieber vorsicht als nachsicht aber
ich muss sagen ich verliere den
überblick wo ich überhaupt hin reisen
darf also mein arbeitgeber liegt im
risiko neben einzel war vor ort nicht
doch hast du geschafft hat und ich
glaube dass diese uneinheitlichkeit die
wir hier in deutschland gerade haben zu
einer verunsicherung beiträgt die auch
im übrigen schwieriger machen wird
dieser einer verantworte er wirklich
sinnvoll umzusetzen
denn ehrlich sagt dazu die natürlich
auch mit ihm gesprochen wenn du sagst
die masten menschen ihren schreiben
state homestake home und dann die
nächste woche auf einer hochzeit genau
das war das paradebeispiel was eben auch
mit eigenverantwortlich china gegen die
wir sponsoren haben gezeigt wir sind ja
auf die hochzeit gegangen ist war ja
auch erlauben aber nicht jeder
eigenverantwortlich handelt und spricht
gleichermaßen haben für alle egal wie
hoch das risiko ist dann ist das ja
genau das gegenteil von gesunde menschen
zwischen rechnen weil ich will ich will
ein beispiel nennen weil natürlich das
infektionsrisiko unterschiedlich
ausgeprägt ist also auch in den
fallzahlen beispielsweise und in
mecklenburg vorpommern sind sozusagen
andere regeln notwendig als
beispielsweise im bereich ihrer war sie
im absoluten aber selbst in der
kriegszeit mit einer mine um lauter und
leiser aber dass im moment viel chaos
heraus und einigen uns darauf dass uns
hier gerade nicht ganz
[Musik]